how is a New York Times best-selling
author different from a Wall Street
Journal or USA Today author
the New York Times bestseller list is
the Holy Grail of lists and you know the
New York Times just has a Mystique and
an Allure that no other publication on
Earth does the Wall Street Journal in
USA Today lists are strictly by the
Numbers whereas the New York Times list
yes they're looking at sales numbers but
they're also they've been open about the
fact that it is an editorial decision a
lot of
um people try to game these lists and
there were companies that were allegedly
for two hundred thousand dollars could
get you on the New York Times bestseller
list there was a scandal a few years ago
a book called handbook for Mortals came
out and it was a why a book and no one
had ever heard of it no one had ever
heard of the author and it it uh hit on
the New York Times list above of the
hate you give which was a why a book
that everybody was obsessed with and
people said what is this book How come
I've never heard of it Twitter got
involved and they uncovered this thing
that the way they had gotten onto the
New York Times list is they had figured
out which bookstores were New York Times
reporting bookstores so it's sort of
like a Nielsen family some stores report
to the list and you have to have sales
you know you can't go and buy 10 000
copies on Amazon it has to be a little
bit of sales everywhere ever since the
handbook from Mortal Scandal the New
York Times started putting a little
dagger which basically says uh yeah they
made the list but were not totally sure
it's like it's basically putting it
putting it into question but they still
will put it on the list a lot of people
don't even know what the dagger means uh
Wall Street Journal in USA Today
um strictly by the numbers
if I self-publish my book is there any
way I can become a New York Times
best-selling author with that book you
absolutely can become a New York Times
best-selling author with a
self-published book it doesn't happen
very often but it absolutely can happen
when someone comes to you and says my
goal is to become a New York Times
best-selling author what is your answer
if somebody says my goal is to become a
New York Times best-selling author
um I often will tell them it's like
walking in to buy a lotto ticket and
saying my goal is to be the jackpot
winner that's awesome I think that's
everybody's goal when they play mulatto
but it doesn't mean it's a very
realistic goal I I'm a big fan of those
things you can control uh therefore I
would rather have a hundred people read
one of my books and have those hundred
people incredibly affected by it have
them want to hire me or my company than
have a hundred thousand people who
aren't really going to care I think it
is about the quality of the reader and
the impact the writer is going to have
on them and not about the numbers
what are the biggest misconceptions
people have about being a New York Times
best-selling author the biggest
misconception people have about being in
New York Times best-selling author is
they think you never have to work again
you're a millionaire a multi-millionaire
you're made for the rest of your life
the reality is being a New York Times
best-selling author is amazing because
you get to say I'm a New York Times
best-selling author ever trust me I dine
out on it as often as I possibly can
um but it doesn't really mean anything
beyond the fact that you can say it I
know somebody who had a number one New
York Times best-selling book not just on
the list number one on the list for week
after week after week who is completely
broke
so it doesn't mean you're set for life
it just means you've you've accomplished
something that many many people want to
accomplish and you should brag about it
for the rest of your life
can you tell us how you did it how did
you become a New York Times best-selling
author well so my book that hit the list
was not party girl people always I'll
tell you they think it is and sometimes
I don't even correct them I'm like yeah
yeah it's a book uh that I wrote for an
actor
um and so we co-wrote it but he actually
never read the book
um and it was what happened is this I
met this actor he said I want to write a
book I said I know an agent who sells
celebrity Memoirs and I called him up
and I said could you sell this book and
he said absolutely and it can be in New
York Times bestseller and so he he
couldn't make any promises but that's
why I agreed to do it and so it um you
know the actor was able to get on Dr
Phil and on the talk and on these other
shows and it hit the list and
um it doesn't matter matter if it hits
the list once it doesn't matter if it's
the e-book or the paperback or the
hardcover it doesn't matter if it's
there's something called the extended
list if it hits the list it's officially
on the list so how I did it is basically
I partnered with somebody that um I
didn't want to partner with because I
knew that would be the result or I hoped
that would be the result and that it
would all be worth it
a memoir has a much better chance I
guess of of getting a publishing deal
and of of hitting this Mark or no I hear
all sorts of things
um I I don't know
um if I'm you know I think they have
separate lists so I
when I originally wrote party girl I sat
there in the office with Regan books and
they said to me why didn't you write a
memoir and it was the week that James
fry was getting like brought down on
Oprah he had written this recovery book
and it turns out he had made things up
and it was like it happened to be the
week that I was meeting with harp with
uh reading books about party girl and I
thought well you can't really be funny
in a memoir you can't really make fun of
yourself you can but it's a lot harder
to in retrospect I do wish I had done a
memoir because
you know there's all these lists of like
these are the best you know addiction
Memoirs and all of these things nobody
ever says like here's a list of the most
useful and best addiction novels that's
not really a thing when the book came
out they called it uh what did Harper
came up with
um they called it reality fiction which
is also now called Auto fiction where
it's kind of fiction it's a Romano clay
it's based on your real life but then
there's a lot of fictional elements to
it
can you be a successful author and never
write a New York Times bestseller a
thousand percent a successful author to
me is someone who publishes a book
they're proud of that helps people and
to me it doesn't have to it doesn't mean
a certain number of sales
it means that it's done at the highest
level and it doesn't even have to mean a
certain length there are successful
books that are a hundred Pages
um I don't think you should go any
shorter than that but but there are
horrible books that are on the New York
Times bestseller list like unreadable
books so there is not it there's you
know it's it doesn't mean it's a success
even if it's on a list
to me
do you remember the first Memoir you
read where you said I want to do this
yeah
um I read a book called permanent
midnight by Jerry Stahl in the late 90s
and I thought this is funny this is dark
but this is funny
then I didn't really think I could do it
then I read this book called going down
by this uh novelist named Jennifer Bell
and it's a novel and it's so funny and I
later became friends with her and she
blurbed one of my later books but I just
I I don't know if I thought I was just
like I wish I could do this this is so
funny and I'm a big fan of humorous
writing
um I'm not like I'm like I like
Fitzgerald and not Hemingway Hemingway
is so serious which sounds fun
um fun but dark that's what I like
um but I will tell you the the way I
actually wrote a book is I was sitting
in
um my old boss's office it was a
magazine that he worked at and I looked
on the shelf and I saw a book written by
a girl we all knew and I picked it up
and I said what's this and he said oh
it's so-and-so's book and I'm like
looked in a real pages and a real cover
and a real publisher and I thought if
she can do it I know I can and that's
when I sat down and started writing how
much money can you make as a New York
Times best-selling author
um I will tell you I've never been more
broke than when I was a New York Times
bestselling author that book I had
gotten in advance of I think it was 75
000 but it took years of my life between
a very unpleasant years
um between the writing the editing the
the putting it out
um and the way I look at it is there are
businesses where one client could pay
you seventy five thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars more than that
so
um
why worry about how much you can make
from an advance or Book Sales when you
can show how well you know how to do
something and have somebody hired to do
that if it's a traditionally published
book that's a lot harder to do because a
traditional publisher they're interested
in bringing people to their publishing
company so so for they put their website
in the book if you're independently or
self-published or hybrid publishing you
get to put your website you get to put a
QR code that brings people to your
newsletter list so I think the you know
the way to really make money is to write
a book that helps people and helps
someone hire you